because for me watching trashy Sakai or
just trash anime in general because
apparently that's my brand or whatever
it's just the reason I do it is because
it's just like it's just the easy turn
your brain off show the season right no
you know like I have to be in a certain
mood to watch something like mornig
artery you know what I mean like I'll
just be like oh I'm just like casually
sit down having having like my lunch or
something I'm like I'm gonna I'm always
like the antithesis of I'm just gonna
put something on yeah
whereas whereas we've with the trashy so
guy like I just sit down for lunch and I
just put it on you know and I just don't
have to think I watch every week and
then I just end and those the shows end
up watching because then they're like
the easiest watch cuz I know I'm getting
into I'm not being challenged you know
I'm just like okay this characters gonna
do that whatever how much of a brain did
she make which is why I can watch them
because they are brain dead yeah I don't
have to think yes you know you know
sometimes where you watch like a good
show right and sometimes you just really
want to be in that right mood to watch
something good but with some with the
trash shows I never have to be in a
certain mood that's true watch it you
know
which is why I've found I've found I've
watched more trash shows because like
like sometimes I don't know I I get ink
I get anxiety sometimes when if I know
I'm not sure if it's a good show but a
mood do you know what I mean what was
the show keep your hands off right right
like that was one of those shows where
I'm like I can't just not like I can't
just like watch this yeah yeah you have
to commit so it's such a passionate
thing where I was like yeah just half
ask this so what's one episode and I
liked what I saw
yeah but because of that I I just never
watched episode two because yeah I had
to be in that mood to watch it never was
yeah it's like really hard to like him
stop and then get back into yeah and it
sucks cuz I know that was a good show I
know it was but I just I didn't care
enough to like find that time to be like
I want to keep watching this and I
thought oh bad cos like everyone was
like this is the best show of the season
yeah I'm just sitting there like
watching like the 100th documentary on
Netflix
like because I have no time I don't know
it's okay I've had that problem a lot
more with anime recent I feel this this
is the reason this is the [ __ ] reason
I still haven't watched full miss
alchemist okay yeah you know it's good I
know it's good and I'm like because
here's the thing I can go years without
watching or reading a manga over of a
series that I know I'm going to love I
but I want to be in the right mood and
it might take years it might take a
[ __ ] decade okay like last year I
finally read 20th century boys and it
went from like I know I was gonna read
this since I basically started getting
into manga - okay yeah this is like I
thought one of my favorite mangas of all
time yeah and it's [ __ ] incredible
it's what I had to wait like so many
years to experience it because I just
wanted to be in that perfect zone to
read it and I'm so glad I did